now to the pacific northwest which is
still suffering from dangerously high
temperatures as crews battle
wildfires all across the region and the
heat
is putting a strain on the power grid
lilia luciano is in seattle which
yesterday reached its hottest day
on record lilia good morning to you
good morning to you tony look the heat
here isn't just oppressive
it's unheard of in fact it's so unusual
that according to u.s census data
less than half of residents in seattle
have no air conditioning
and that leaves a lot of people
scrambling to find ways to cool off
however they can
for the first time ever seattle reached
triple digit temperatures monday
for a third day in a row everything sold
out like today we couldn't get any ice
everything is completely gone for days a
dome of stifling heat has
parked itself over the pacific northwest
causing some restaurants like this
drive-in to temporarily
close and roads to buckle tanker trucks
in seattle hose down drawbridges
to try to keep the steel from expanding
here we go
larry snyder calls himself a community
helper taking donations to give water to
the homeless
or anyone in need water is the one thing
that the
people on the street are really short of
right now in portland which reached a
record-breaking 116 degrees on monday
the extreme heat was enough to bring
light rail and streetcar service to a
halt
transportation officials posted this
picture writing
here's what the heat is doing to our
power cables
some cities even had to close public
pools
in seattle the hot pool deck made
conditions unsafe
part of the reason i moved here was to
come in the summer
to have relief from arizona heat and i
seem to have brought it with me
so not i'm not real thrilled
while temperatures are supposed and
expected to come down this week
they'll still be in the 90s and that is
20 degrees above
average and if you're in seattle and
cleverly think of getting a hotel room
think again i'll tell you story gail my
crew and i resorted to couch surfing
with friends and family
because there are no rooms well you're
the best looking couch surfer i've seen
lily
leona thank you so much good to see you
lilia luciano thank you very much